So last time we found out how
to evaluate options,
especially stopping options
where you don't have so many
options.
You either do something or you
don't do it.
That's the simplest kind of
option.
And we discovered through two
examples, at least,
that the option is worth more
than people realize.
So this time we're going to
apply that--
and that the way to figure out
exactly what it's worth and
exactly what to do is to work by
backward induction.
So this time we're going to
apply that reasoning to the two
most important options in the
economy,
one is callable bonds and a
much more important one is the
mortgage option.
And all of you at some time in
your lives will probably own
houses and have a mortgage
option and have to think about
what kind of mortgage to get and
what the option is.
So I want to teach you how to
think about that problem.
So let's start with the
callable bond problem.
Uh-oh, I forgot to turn this on.
So let's start here with the
callable bond problem.
So callable bonds are issued by
corporations and they pay,
usually, an interest rate,
say 9 percent.
So the bond pays 9 percent,
9 percent and then some years
later it pays 109,
but at any point in time you
have the option,
the company has the option of
calling the bond,
and calling it for--so it's
going to pay 9 100 at the end,
so here it's 9.
So at any time the company has
the option of calling the bond.
So what does that mean?
It means after it's paid the
9--the company's issued a bond
promising to pay 9 for say 10
years and then the principal in
the 10th year,
this is year 10,
the total of 109.
So that's the simplest possible
bond.
And the company occasionally
has the option,
we'll see in a minute why it
would want this option,
has the option of saying,
"Okay,
we don't want to make the rest
of those payments.
We want to get out of our
promise.
We've just paid you 9.
We'll pay off the extra 100
that we're eventually going have
to owe and we'll call it a
day."
So this is the payment and this
is the remaining balance.
So for a callable bond the
remaining balance is always 100.
So it's pretty obvious that if
you've made an arrangement,
so I owe you--like for example
the prototypical mortgage was
exactly of this kind.
Somebody borrows money from you
and they say,
"I promise to pay you 9
dollars a year until the last
year when I'm going to pay you
109.
This is called,
for those old mortgages it was
called the balloon payment,
but in typical bonds it's just
the principal payment,
the 100 face value of the bond.
So the person who borrowed the
money and has agreed to pay off
over the years,
he might have a reason why the
house he put up as collateral is
no longer going to be his house.
He might want to move in which
case the lender doesn't have a
house anymore backing the loan
and they have to have some way
of resolving the loan and ending
it.
So the question is,
after you've made a payment,
how can you resolve the rest of
the loan which is supposed to go
on for 6 more years?
Well, you just agree to pay 100
and then you call it quits.
So that's a typical kind of
bond.
A non-callable bond is,
you've committed to paying the
9 dollars and the 109 at the end
and you have no option to get
out of the thing.
So we want to study what the
difference is in value between
the non-callable bond where
you're obliged to pay the whole
thing until the end,
and the callable bond where you
can get out of it by paying 100.
And it's easy to see why a
callable bond might have been
invented,
especially for a mortgage when
you've got this balloon payment
because you might want to
dissolve the debt.
But by putting in this option
to dissolve the debt you
drastically change the value of
the promise,
and that's what we want to
calculate,
how much that changes.
So why might it change?
Well, the interest rates might
change.
They might go up or down.
Soon we're going to have them
going up or down in a more
complicated way,
but suppose that the interest
rate starts somewhere like at 8
percent,
maybe, and it could go up to
some number.
Now, I'm always going to do a
geometric random walk.
This has become very
fashionable in finance and you
should be asking the question,
is it special that we only have
two possibilities?
Life has many more than two
possibilities.
Suppose we had hundreds of
possibilities,
would that make a difference?
The answer is it's not going to
make a difference,
but we're going to have to see
why.
So in a geometric random walk
literally the thing can go up or
down each period.
So what does it go to if this
is r_0?
The next period we say it goes
to r_0 times e to the
volatility, which I usually call
sigma, plus maybe a drift,
plus d.
And here it's going to go to
r_0e--
let's write it with a little
more room--
r_0 e to the minus
sigma plus d,
so what's happened here?
The interest rate started at 8
percent.
It gets multiplied by e to the
d, which is just a number,
so it's maybe tending to go up
over time if d is positive or if
d is 0--
think of d = 0--r_0
on average is going to stay at
r_0,
but there's some uncertainty.
Maybe the interest rate goes up.
We multiply it by some number,
e to the sigma,
and then we multiply it by the
reciprocal of the same number or
we divide it by e to the sigma.
So using the exponential
notation just makes the
computations in the computer
easier because the computer's
adding numbers.
This thing over here is going
to be r_0 e to the 2
sigma 2d, right?
And this will just be
r_0 e to the 2 d,
and this will be r_0
e to the minus 2 sigma 2 d.
So the computer in calculating
the interest rate at every step
is adding exponents and it makes
the calculation when you're
doing gazillions of nodes much
faster.
So that's why it's traditional
to use this notation,
but really all I'm saying is
you multiply or divide by the
same number to see what the next
interest rate is,
and on top of that you might be
sort of increasing all the
things over time just because
you think the interest rates are
going up over time.
So that's how we're modeling
uncertainty, and everybody is
supposed to understand what the
probabilities are of these
moves.
So for now that's going to be
our model of uncertainty and in
a few minutes I'm going to try
and indicate why complicating it
won't have much effect.
So are there any questions?
This notation I hope isn't too
complicated.
Are there any questions about
the interest rate process I'm
assuming, the uncertainty that
people are facing?
Yeah?
Student: Why is that
middle probability on the far
right, r_0 is always
equal to
>?
Prof: Because I'm
assuming that if there weren't
uncertainty the interest rate
was going to keep steadily
rising by multiplying by the
constant e to the d.
So here I've multiplied it by e
to the d.
Here I'm multiplying it again
by e to the d,
and I'm going to multiply it
again by e to the d.
So if d is 1 tenth of a percent
it means that the interest rate
is rising at 1 tenth of a
percent every period.
You might just think interest
rates are going to get higher in
the future.
You might have a more
complicated function than
steadily rising or steadily
falling.
It's just that this is the
simplest to add a little
complication without making it
too complicated.
Steadily rising or steadily
falling and binomial uncertainty
were the easiest simple things I
could do.
Of course a more realistic
thing would do more complicated
things.
Any other questions about what
this means?
I know this can be confusing,
this notation,
so let's just figure out the
notation.
Make sure you understand it
before I move on because it's
really nothing but notation.
I'm just saying the interest
rate is 8 percent today.
It can go up a little or down a
little and then after that it
can go up or down and the
percentage rise and fall is
always going to be the same
relative to a drift and the
drift might be 0,
the drift might be positive.
So to take an example,
let's take an example here.
Did I plug everything in?
Yes.
This is a spreadsheet that you
have called callable bond.
I did a little work on it,
but not much.
It's basically your spreadsheet.
Everything is plugged in here.
You're seeing that, right?
So what I've done is I've said
let's take over here the year,
so here are the years,
0,1, 2,3, blah up to 31 or
something.
Then the bond coupon rate is 9
percent, so the bond is going to
pay 9 dollars,
9 percent.
The face is always 100.
It'll pay 9 dollars until the
end.
So if I take the bond maturity
of 30 down here I've got the 9
dollar payments and I've got the
remaining principal,
the remaining balance,
what you could pay to dissolve
the contract.
You could after the first year,
after paying 9,
immediately afterwards you
could pay 100 and say forget
about the whole thing.
So that's that,
and so it goes all the way to
year 30,
and year 30 you see you're
paying 109,
and then the bond is over,
109 and by then the bond is
over,
there's nothing to talk about.
So now I start off the interest
rate somewhere at 8 percent,
and I take the volatility,
it's always said in hundreds,
I take the volatility of 16.
That means sigma = 16 over 100,
because that's the way people
talk about volatility of 16
percent.
So that is a sort of standard
volatility,
12 or 16 percent is about the
annual volatility of these
things traditionally,
so I've taken the volatility at
16 percent.
So I take the drift of 0 to
make that simple.
The d's disappearing,
so what does that mean?
It means that whatever the
thing was last period when it
moves to here I take the old
number--
at the top there if you read
this, this is the up multiplier.
I just take e to the sigma d
and that's what this says over
here, exponent of--it just says
that.
So that's the up multiplier and
that's the down multiplier.
Let's just see how that looks.
So if I look at the interest
rates I start at 8 percent and
they can go up by that
multiplier, 16 percent up or 16
percent down.
And see if you take 8 percent
you add 16 percent to it,
slightly more than 16 percent,
because e to the .16 is a
little bit more than 16 percent.
You take 8,16 percent up is
about 9.3 percent interest and
16 percent down you go from 8
percent to 6.8 percent.
And things just go up or down
so that's the uncertainty.
So that's what interest rates
are going to do.
So everybody knows that you
start at 8 percent and interest
rates can go up or down by 16
percent for the next 30 years.
The question is,
what's the value of the bond?
Well, if you couldn't call
it--please interrupt me if
you're not following.
If you couldn't call it,
non-callable bond,
why would you expect it to have
such a high price?
Well, because the interest rate
is, sorry, the interest rate,
remember, is only 8 percent and
on average it's going to stay at
8 percent.
It could go up or down,
but it's always coming
back--the middle thing there is
always 8 percent.
So if you look in the middle
it's 8 percent,
8 percent, 8 percent,
8 percent, so sort of the
geometric average is 8 percent.
On average it's going to be 8
percent.
That's less than the payment,
9, so the poor bondholder is
overpaying,
paying 9 every year when the
interest rate is only 8 percent
and on average is going to be 8
percent.
So obviously the bond issuer is
giving a very good deal to the
buyer by paying 9 when the
interest rate's only 8 percent.
And you know how you calculate
this.
At every step you'd have to do
it by backward induction.
So you'd write down,
and we've done this before,
the value at every node
V_S,
so if I take a node here what's
the value of it?
I don't know if I need to do a
concrete example.
How do I do this by backward
induction?
So I keep going like that,
right?
And then life is going to end.
This is the last payment
somewhere.
Let's say the last payment is
here so you're going to get 109
no matter what because that's
the last period 109,109,
109,109.
So we know what the value is
here at the end because it's 0
beyond this point,
and we know what the value is
here.
You're going to pay 109 no
matter what so you just take the
interest rate back here.
So we know what the value is
here.
So the question is if you
figured out the value at the end
of the tree,
which is trivial because at the
very end you're just going to
get 109 for sure,
can you figure out what the
value is at the beginning of the
tree.
And the way you do that is for
every node you say to yourself,
it doesn't matter which node
you are like this one or that
one, let's call is node S.
So the value of node S,
this is the value just after
paying the coupon.
So you've paid the coupon,
you've paid the 9,
now what's the value.
Well, the non-call price,
so let's do non-call,
non-call bond,
what is the value going to be?
Well, just after paying the 9
here what's the value of what's
left?
So you're going to have to go
up here.
First of all you're going to
discount by the interest rate
here, so it's 1 over (1
r_S),
so you're discounting by the
interest rate there.
Then half the time you'll go up.
So what will you have to do if
you go up?
You'll have to pay 9 because
that's the required payment,
and then you'll be left in the
same situation except that
you'll be at the up state,
whatever the value is
there--plus V_Sup.
If this node is S this node we
call S_up and this
node we call S_down.
So I'm doing this by backward
induction, remember.
I'm saying, suppose towards the
end of the tree I figured out
what is the value of the bond
just after making the coupon
payment.
Since there are no coupon
payments at the end I know the
value is 0,
so having done it at the end,
and working my way backwards
now by induction,
I can figure out the value at
any previous node.
So suppose I'm here and I've
already figured out the value of
all future nodes.
The value here is simply going
to be,
value here is,
just after the coupon payment,
is going to be--I'm going to
discount at the interest rate
here,
1 r_S.
Half the time I'm going to have
to go up here,
in which case I'm going to pay
9 and then what am I going to
do?
I'm going to be at a situation
where I've just made the coupon
payment and I see what the value
left is.
Well, that's the number we
already calculated.
So V_Sup 1 half--if I
go down I'm down to here.
It's 9 again V_Sdown.
So that's pretty simple,
and now I just have to solve it
by backward induction.
So that's what I did in this
tree.
Here are the interest rates,
and now back here here's the
present value of a non-callable
bond.
So at any node,
let's pick one like this one,
what's the value?
It says it's 1 over (1 the
interest rate) times the
probability .5,
that's 1 half,
times the payment,
that's 9 dollars,
plus what the value would be if
I went up because J 149 is this
node.
That's J 149 here,
so it's just exactly what I
wrote,
50 percent probability J 4 is
the 9 dollars at the top plus
the value of what I would get
here,
plus 1 half times the same 9
dollars I'd have to pay if I
went down,
plus the value that I'd get
down here.
So that's an extremely simple
calculation to do,
and because Excel is a
brilliant--as I said created by
Kapor whose sister was my
classmate and was two years
ahead of me at Yale--
Excel immediately
understands--he called it
Lotus--
immediately understands that if
you give all these directions
you can't figure out the value
here unless you know what the
value is forward.
So Excel understands that you
should keep going forward and
starting at the end,
and at the end it knows what
the value is because it's just
0.
So having got the value 0 at
the end it then works backwards
all the way through the tree and
gets the value at the beginning
and gets 113.
So it's exactly what we want to
do,
and he's just written this
brilliant program that
understands if there's a
dependency you can't calculate
this without knowing this.
He says, "Okay,
I don't know this.
I'll go forward into the
program to here.
I can't do these either.
I'll go all the way to the end.
Now everything is 0,
so I know all these numbers.
Now step-by-step I can go
backwards and get all of
them."
That's what Excel is doing and
it does it instantly.
So there's no doubt about that,
right?
You all are way ahead of me on
that.
So the value's 113,
that's a huge number,
so obviously it's a very
generous company.
The company may not want to be
so generous, so the company
says, look, we want to be able
to call the bond at 100.
So that simple option,
what's it going to be?
What's the value going to be?
Well, obviously the company
could call it right away at 100.
So it's going to make the value
go all the way down to 100
because the company now has the
option,
whenever it wants to,
like at the very beginning
before making the first payment,
it could pay 100 here,
or it could pay the 9 dollars
and then pay 100 here.
So the question is,
should the company do it,
and when do you think the
company will exercise the
option?
Why wouldn't the company
exercise the option right away?
So here it is.
The bond's worth 113.
Every period the company's
promising to pay 9 dollars.
That's like a 9 percent
interest.
The interest rate's in the
economy only 8 percent at the
beginning here.
So it's losing money right from
the start.
Why shouldn't the company just
say, "Okay,
we gave ourselves the option,
we're taking it right away.
We're going to just pay you 100
and cancel the whole thing at
the beginning."
Why wouldn't they do that?
Okay, hang on for one second.
Someone else,
why wouldn't they do that?
You see, the puzzle is,
the company has promised to pay
9 dollars forever.
That's like 9 percent on a
100-dollar coupon.
The interest rate is only 8
percent now, so the company's
paying more money,
9 dollars.
It could have borrowed and only
had to pay 8 dollars.
So the guy buying it is getting
this huge bonus.
He's getting 9-dollar coupons
instead of 8-dollar coupons.
He's probably telling his
friends who aren't marking to
market, look at my return.
I've got 9 dollars the first
year.
Look at that great 9 percent
return I got on my investment of
100.
Why won't the company call it
right at the beginning?
What's the company waiting for?
Yep?
Student: It's hoping
that the interest rate will go
back up.
Prof: Back up,
exactly, because if the
interest rates go way up--
after a very short amount of
time if the company gets lucky
the interest rates are going to
go up.
So here are the interest rates,
right?
So after a very short amount of
time, 2 years,
you get the up thing,
the interest rates are 11
percent.
So all of a sudden the company
is looking great.
It's borrowed at 9 percent and
the interest rates are actually
11 percent.
Effectively it's borrowing from
the guy, 9 percent,
and it's able to invest the
money at 11 percent.
To put it another way,
the present value of the
payment's left from then are
much less than 100.
So it's glad it made the deal.
And on the other hand,
if the interest rate goes down
far enough then the company will
be able to call the thing.
Present value of the payments
if it couldn't call would be way
higher.
Because it can call it can
never suffer worse than having
to pay 100.
So you see that if the interest
rates are going up or down and
you couldn't call it then when
interest rates go up that's
really good news for the company
because now the interest rates
are over 9 percent on average
going forward,
so actually the present value
of payments is 98.
That's less than 100.
On the other hand if interest
rates go down then the company's
really screwed,
now the present value of what
it owes is 127.
At the beginning it's 113,
so as interest rates go further
and further down the company's
made a worse and worse bond
issue,
but it doesn't suffer very much
because of that because it can
always get out of its deal by
calling it.
So in fact, astonishingly,
it doesn't even call the first
time.
So here's the value.
When the company behaves
optimally it won't call the
first time.
When interest rates go up it
says, "Ah-ha!
We're going to make money,
that's great,
but when interest rates go down
now the interest rate's 6
percent and it's still paying 9.
The company is still not going
to call the bond.
It won't call the bond until
the interest rates go down all
the way to 5 percent.
So anyway, by backward
induction you get the value of
the callable bond is 95,
which is 95.529,
which is a lot--let's write
those down, in fact.
So the callable bond,
95.529, and non-call was 113
point something,
which I forgot already.
So I hope you're following
because this is going to get a
lot more surprising when we do
mortgages, but it's the same
logic, 113.236.
So the call option is worth 18
percent to the bond.
It's a huge thing.
It sounds so simple.
Of course you should dissolve
the thing for a value of 100.
That's the only natural thing
to do.
So it's perfectly reasonable,
you would think,
for the company to give itself
that option.
"Look guys we're borrowing
money, but there may be some
reason why things get too
complicated.
Our company might close down.
We want to keep our promise,
so we just want to pay off the
loan at 100, so give us that
option even if our company
doesn't close down."
Well, the company has just
taken an incredibly valuable
option.
Instead of making a promise
worth 113, it's made a promise
worth 95.
So any questions about that?
You could all get that and you
all see why that's happening,
and it's a bigger number than
you'd expect.
Yep?
Student: When should
they call it?
Prof: When should they
call it?
You can tell when they should
call it because--you'll know
when they call it because if
they do call it what's the
value?
So I didn't work out
the--what's the backward
induction?
Sorry.
So let's write down the formula
when you do call it.
How could I have forgotten to
do that?
What do you do when you do call
it?
So value, how do you figure
this out?
I just skipped this, sorry.
Value of callable bond,
so V_S,
what is that going to equal?
Now you've got an option.
So V_S,
remember this is value just
after coupon payment.
So what is the value just after
the coupon payment?
That's when you have to call.
So in a second you'll see why
that's the way the rule works.
So just after the coupon
payment what's the value of the
bond?
Well now that you have the
option you can pay the minimum
of the remaining balance.
It's 100 all the time.
This is just going to be 100.
You could pay 100 or you could
keep going.
So if you keep going it's going
to be 1 r_S times the
same thing,
1 half, and then you're going
to have to make the coupon
payment the next up--
so just a second,
where should we go?
So here this is the interest
rate, so at any node,
you can pick any one like here
in the tree, this one.
That's the interest rate,
so at that node you could,
if you wanted to after making
the coupon payment there you
could pay the 100 and say,
"Okay, we've made the
payment.
I'm making 100 more.
Let's just call the whole thing
quits," but if you don't
you're going to move on,
and when you move on you're
going to go either up to here,
so that's with probability 1
half.
You have to make the coupon
payment and then again you'll
have the option of paying your
way out of it,
dissolving the contract or
continuing.
So you just have V_SU
because that's exactly the value
just after making the coupon
payment at node S_U.
That's V_SU,
and so it's going to take into
account that you're minimizing
something.
So you see, V_S,
the value at any node,
takes into account you could
minimize by possibly paying the
balance and dissolving it or you
could continue.
And so if you continue and
things go up you have to make
the coupon and then you're going
to face a choice,
but we assume by backward
induction you've already figured
out the value of that thing.
Maybe it's paying the 100.
Maybe it's not paying the
hundred whatever that is,
plus 1 half times 9
V_SD.
So the only difference between
this callable--
non-call case and the call case
is you notice that the second
term is exactly the same in the
two cases,
but here we've added the
minimum of 100 in that because
you either could continue or you
could pay 100.
Of course the values,
V_SU up here and
V_S,
are not the same as the
V_S's here because
they've all been concatenated by
taking the minimum with 100.
So the computer now is going to
solve this by backward
induction, and now how can you
tell what the computer has
decided to do?
If the computer said it's a
good time to call that means the
value at that point is going to
be 100 because it's called by
paying the remaining balance
which is 100.
So if you go to the present
value of non-call you get all
these present values.
As the interest rate goes down
you get crushed,
of course, because you have the
same payments and lower interest
rates, you're discounting by
less.
But the callable bond,
see, you shouldn't call here.
It's 99.9 so that means when
the computer took the minimum
100 in this thing it took this
which was 99.
It didn't use the option to
call at 100, but if things go
down again then it's going to
call at 100.
So it's got a threshold here
where the interest rate has to
go pretty far down before it
calls at 100.
It has to go down twice,
but you notice this threshold.
As time goes on the threshold
is going to get tighter.
So even if you're at the same
interest rate four years,
you know, this is 1,2,
3,4, this is 5 years later,
and the interest rate's gone
down once below the minimum bar
here--
five years later you will call
when the interest rate is,
instead of 8 percent,
is 6.8 percent,
but 1 year later you won't call
if it's 6.8 percent,
and why is that?
Well, why is that?
How come if in the first year
the interest rate went from--
remember it started at 8
percent and it goes down to 6.8
percent here you don't call,
on the other hand if things had
stayed the same for a few years
and then in year 5,
or year whatever this--how many
years have we got here,
1,2, 3, no, year 0,1,
2,3, 4, so if in year 4 the
interest rate goes down to--
oh, year 5 the interest rate
goes down to 6.8 percent.
In year 1 if the interest rate
went down from 8 percent to 6.8
percent you wouldn't call,
but if the interest rate sort
of bounces around and then in
year 5 it's back down at 6.8
percent you will call.
Why would you call here even
though in exactly the same
situation you didn't call here?
Why call here and not here?
You can tell where you call
because those are 100s and the
computer's picked the minimum
equal to 100.
So why is it that it's going to
call here, but not here even
though the interest rates are
exactly the same,
6.8 percent in both cases?
Yes?
Student: Because you
can't get to the kind of really
high interest rates from that
point five years later.
There's not enough time left.
Prof: Exactly.
So the point is the only reason
not to call here--you're paying
through the nose,
it's horrible.
The interest rate is 6 percent,
you're paying 9.
It's terrible,
but you're hoping maybe things
are going to turn around.
The interest rate's going to
soar then it's going to be a
great deal for me.
So I'm willing to have some
short run losses in case I get a
gigantic gain on the upside,
and I know that I'm protected
on the downside because if
things go down again I can cut
my losses and just call it 100.
But if you run out of time,
here the interest rate's 6.8,
it's still way below 9 percent
which is the coupon you're
paying and you don't have much
time for the interest rates to
go back up,
you better call then and cut
your losses,
exactly.
So that's the whole logic of
the thing.
So any questions about that?
And as I said,
the option is worth much more
than it seems.
Could you all do a problem like
this?
You'll find out.
So now let me just do one more
example.
I want to do an aside here.
Suppose that we had a trinomial
tree instead of binomial tree.
So I have the same picture,
but instead of two things
happening I say three things
could happen or five things
could happen.
So I would take the same tree
and put this here.
I'd always allow for something
happening in the middle.
And then, of course,
it gets more complicated and
I'm not going to be able to draw
it because now this thing,
three things could happen from
here,
and from here three things
could happen.
From here I have three things,
so I have trinomial tree like
that, right, where always three
things could happen.
So from here I could go here,
stay the same or go up.
Now, if I had a trinomial tree,
and of course you could think
of an N-nomial tree,
would I keep the same numbers
here?
Well, I can't keep the same
numbers because if I have 1 half
and 1 half that doesn't allow
any probability for going in the
middle.
So I'll put 1 quarter here,
and 1 quarter.
Now, what do I have to do to
these numbers?
Well, the drift I'm going to
leave the same because on
average it's still going to go
up by d.
So this was,
remember, r_0 e to
the minus sigma d.
So this is the probability 1
half.
I just made up three numbers,
1 quarter, 1 quarter and 1 half
for the trinomial tree.
Suppose those are my numbers?
If I want to make this tree
comparable to the binomial
tree--what does it mean to be
comparable?
It means that the standard
deviation and the expectation of
the interest rate ought to be
the same.
So I'm using the fact that if
they're normally distributed
random variables all I need to
know--
so if there were millions of
successor interest rates and I
took them with this--
if there are millions of these
successor interest rates then as
long as the standard deviation
and the expectation were the
same,
no matter how I put the
probabilities I'd get almost the
same variable because it would
be normally distributed with
that standard deviation and that
expectation,
and normally distributed,
as I said,
means it's determined by
standard deviation and
expectation.
So I've just picked 1 quarter,
1 half and 1 quarter.
It's as if I had two moves
where you could get two ups to
go here, an up or a down,
or a down or an up to go here,
and two downs to go here.
That's why a picked 1 quarter,
1 half and 1 quarter.
It's like I added 2 six-month
moves here and called it a
1-year move.
So if I keep dividing the
process and having it happen
quicker and quicker,
by the central limit theorem
I'm going to get something
normally distributed with a
corresponding standard deviation
and mean.
So what is going to end up as
the standard deviation here and
here?
Well, I know to get the same
variance before,
I had 1 half sigma squared 1
half sigma squared that equaled
sigma squared,
but now my variance is going to
be 1 quarter sigma--
this is the new sigma hat
squared, 1 quarter sigma hat
squared because I'll go down
whatever this sigma,
so now I should put a sigma hat
here.
So 1 quarter sigma hat squared.
So if I look at the variance of
the exponent it's going to be a
1 quarter sigma hat squared 1
quarter sigma hat squared 1 half
times 0 because half the time
you just get the average.
So therefore it means 1 half
sigma hat squared has to equal
sigma squared.
So therefore sigma hat squared
has to equal 2 sigma squared,
and therefore sigma hat has to
equal the square root of 2 times
sigma.
So I should put the square root
of 2 here and the square root of
2 here.
So now if I do a trinomial,
for the trinomial to be similar
to the binomial the binomial
would be sort of here and here,
and the trinomial there's a lot
probability,
you're stuck in the middle.
So to get the same kind of
average spread I'm going to have
to have this thing sticking
further out and this thing
sticking further out,
but if I choose my numbers by
multiplying by the square root
of 2 here,
and the square root of 2 here,
the standard deviation of this
trinomial is the same as the
standard deviation of the
binomial and the expectation of
the two are the same.
And I could do the same thing
with an N-nomial or an
any-number thing I wanted to and
I could always pick the standard
deviation properly,
pick these nodes properly so
that I had the same standard
deviation and expectation as I
did with the original binomial
tree.
So just because I've got three
nodes or five nodes on average
they can turn out to be the
same,
and the average spread,
the average spread squared can
also be the same as the
binomial.
And if I do that I'm going to
get a shockingly similar answer.
So let's just see what we get.
So what do I have to do now?
I have to go to trinomial.
So what did we do here?
We did--9 percent was the
coupon, and the interest rates
start at 8 percent,
and the volatility was 16.
So if I go to trinomial,
I put 9 percent to start,
30 years, 8 percent the
starting rate and volatility is
16,
and now I have to do the up
multiplier,
and by doing that you see I've
multiplied up there in that
formula there's a square root of
2 there,
2 square root of 2.
So I've got just a slightly
more complicated thing.
I've just multiplied by the
square root of 2 and that's how
I've got all my nodes,
so otherwise it's the same
thing and I do the same backward
induction except instead of
being 1 half,
1 half I put 1 quarter here,
and 1 quarter here,
so it'll be 1 quarter
V_SU 1 quarter
V_SD 1 half,
you stay the same,
which will be 9
V_Ssame,
whatever that is--so I probably
lost you.
So let me just say I want to
convince you that this binomial
assumption is not such a special
case.
So you should be thinking to
yourself, two things happening
next year, that's ridiculous.
I could imagine a million
things happening next year.
So I say, okay I believe it.
A million things could happen
next year,
so I'm going to write down a
million things,
not any million things,
I'm going to say let's suppose
that instead of two things
happening in a year I say I
divide what can happen over the
year into a million different up
and down moves.
Now, in order to replicate sort
of the original binomial,
those million up and down
moves, let's say 250 of them,
1 every day,
those daily moves,
of course,
are going to be much smaller
than the 1-year move.
But if I make the drift be the
old drift divided by 250,
and the new standard deviation
of the tiny things be the right
ratio of the standard deviation,
then when I compute the
standard deviation of all the
nodes here I'll get the same
standard deviation as the
binomial and the same drift in
the binomial.
So if I ended up with 3 nodes
here I would just be multiplying
by the square root of 2.
And so by having a trinomial
thing with a slightly adjusted
move up and down,
slightly spreading it and
putting some probability in the
middle,
I can have the same variance
and the same expectation.
If I had thousands of nodes
here I'd also have the same
variance and the same
expectation, and so I did it
just for the trinomial.
So let's see what happens to
the value.
If we look now at the interest
rates, it was an uglier thing.
I couldn't do it quite as--I
was too lazy to do it as neatly,
so the interest rates started
at 8 percent and now they can go
up to 10 or down to 6.3,
and then the next period they
can go up to 12 and 1 half.
So you see there are different
moves here.
Remember the other one was 6.8
and 9, so if you don't get the
same interest rate right away
you move more violently up or
down.
So these three things,
these two are spread out
further than this.
So what happens to the price?
The present value of the
non-call bond is 113.230 and
what was it before,
113.236.
It's not so different.
And if I look now at the value
of the callable bond it's 95.142
and what was it before,
95.529, a little bit different.
So you can see that the
trinomial thing gives you almost
the same answer as the binomial.
So I don't want to say anything
more than that.
So no matter how many nodes you
have in the tree the binomial's
going to give a good
approximation provided that we
shrink the periods.
Instead of looking at a year,
looking at daily moves or
minute by minute moves,
as long as those are binomial
over a year a million things can
happen.
And so you can restrict
yourself to binomial without any
loss of generality just taking
the time period short enough,
because if it's a daily
binomial over a year there's 250
outcomes or something and so for
a minute there are thousands of
outcomes over a year even though
each move is binomial and you'll
get the same answer.
So that's that.
All right, so we've done the
callable bond idea,
and the call option is worth a
lot.
Now, let's take a more concrete
example,
the one that you've all heard
your parents talking about,
if you don't own a house
yourself, which is a mortgage.
And I just want to do the same
thing and help you start to
think about how to value
mortgages.
So what's a mortgage?
A mortgage is,
you don't have the balloon
payment at the end.
You pay the same amount each
period.
Let's take a mortgage.
So which example have I done
here?
So I've got a mortgage rate of
7 percent, a 7 percent coupon,
you can see,
and it's a 30 year fixed rate
mortgage.
Now, how much does that mean
you have to pay every year?
So, every year,
what are you going to pay?
You're not going to pay 7.
What this means is,
whatever X you pay--
every year that's your annual
payment--
the 30th year you're still
going to pay X,
but if I took this all over
1.07 X over 1.07 squared this
over 1.07 cubed this over 1.07
to the 30th I would get 100,
equals 100.
So that's how X is chosen,
so that the mortgage is an
annuity of constant X whose
present value at the coupon is
equal to 100.
That's how you define the
payment on a mortgage,
but a mortgage has to be
defined more completely than
that.
You also have to say what do
you get by dissolving the
mortgage, how much do you have
to pay?
So right away you have to pay
100.
What would you have to pay here
if you dissolved the mortgage
right after the--
so remaining balance equals
payment just after coupon
necessary to dissolve the
mortgage.
So at the very beginning the
guy gave you 100.
If you want to dissolve it and
undo it you should be able to do
it for 100, but what about after
the very first year you've paid
X?
By the way, X in this case is
going to work out to 8.05.
If you solve for X you get 8.05.
That 8.05 discounted at 7
percent gives you 100.
So obviously X has to be bigger
than 7 because if it were 7
everywhere you'd need 107 at the
very end to make it 100.
Of course at the very end
that's 30 years later,
so that extra 100 can be
compensated by an extra 1,1.05
all the way along.
1.05 all the way along is just
the same as an extra 100 at the
end.
So the payment is 8.05.
So if you're paying a 7 percent
mortgage your annual payment is
going to be more than 7 percent.
It's going to be 8.05.
So that's the 7 percent coupon
of the mortgage,
coupon of mortgage.
Now, if you want to get out of
the mortgage it's called
prepaying.
What would you have to pay here
to get out of the mortgage do
you suppose?
What's the only logical thing
to have written in the contract?
Student: Penalty.
Prof: Well,
you could pay a penalty,
but what if you don't want to
have a penalty?
Then what should the guy pay to
get out of the mortgage?
Yeah?
Student: The remaining
balance.
Prof: The remaining
balance, yes,
but what is the remaining
balance?
That's the question,
what is the remaining balance.
Well, maybe you know what the
answer is.
Student: It's the
present value at the time.
Prof: Of what's left.
So the guy here,
the remaining balance,
B_1,
ought to be this number without
this.
You've only got 29 payments,
only you're going to put a 1
here now, right?
So it's B_1 squared
and B to the 29th because you've
made the first coupon payment.
You've got 29 years left
assuming the same terms as
before it still is a 7 percent
coupon,
so you should discount the
remaining 29 years at 7 percent
to get B_1.
So that's what B_1 is.
So as you can see in the thing
B_1 is 98.94.
Now, 98.94 is an interesting
number.
You notice that the 8.05 minus
7 happens to equal--that plus
B_1 has to equal 100,
which is B_0.
So why is that?
So you started owing the guy
100.
You've borrowed 100,
you own him 100,
and he's sort of charging you 7
percent interest.
That's the way the deal works.
So you would have expected to
only pay 7 dollars next period.
That's to keep up with the 7
percent interest.
Remember, why did the old
mortgages go from the balloon
payment to this?
Because in the Depression in
1933 every single farmer,
practically,
who owed the 109 because his
mortgage was coming up
defaulted.
So the lenders decided they
didn't want to be facing that
situation where a guy owed 109.
They'd rather have the guy pay
X every period where there's
never this gigantic payment that
he's going to default.
In fact, by paying X every
period that lender's in a safer
and safer situation.
Why is that?
Because he's asking for X which
is 8 dollars even though the
interest is 7 dollars,
so the homeowner is paying
8.05.
The interest was only 7.
So he's making an extra payment
of 1.05 dollars.
So what do you do with the
extra 1.05 dollars?
You write down the balance.
You say you've overpaid me by
1.05.
I'm no longer going to say you
owe 100.
You're going to owe,
now, 100 - 1.05.
1.05 had a few decimal places
after it, and so it's going to
be 98.94136.
So that's this gap,
so B_0 -
B_1.
The balance went down by
exactly what the overpayment was
beyond the interest.
And so the next time the
balance is going to go down even
further because the next time
the balance is only
B_1.
The next time what the guy
owes--if he was just paying the
interest he ought to owe only
.07 times B_1,
and yet he's still going to be
paying 8.05,
so B_1 -
B_2.
So the balance B_2 is
going to go down even more,
so the gap from 100 to
B_1 is a very small
one.
It's going to be bigger from
B_1 to B_2
and keep getting bigger and
bigger because each time the
guy's paying 8.05,
but what he owes,
the balance that he owes on,
that he's basically borrowed
the money on is a smaller and
smaller number,
so he's overpaying the 7
percent interest by a bigger and
bigger amount and the balance
goes down by more and more each
time.
All right, to put it another
way, if you take the first thing
is, B_1 is X times
1.07,1.07 squared,
1.07 to the 29.
B_2 is X 1.07 blah,
blah, blah, X times 1.07 to the
28th.
So the difference between this
and this is the last payment
which is 1 over 1.07 to the
29th.
The difference between this and
this is the last payment which
is 1 over 1.07 to the 30th.
And so as that final maturity
gets smaller and smaller the gap
gets bigger and bigger,
so I'm just saying the same
thing in different ways.
So are there any questions
about this?
Did I go too fast or are you
with me?
Somebody ask a question if
you're lost.
Yes?
Student: Why don't we
discount B_1?
Prof: Why do I what?
Student: Discount
B_1?
Prof: I'm sorry,
why do I--say it louder.
Student: Discount.
Prof: Why do I discount
what?
Student: Why don't we
because you are subtracting the
amount from the 0
>?
Prof: Yes this,
so let me say this again.
You borrowed 100.
The coupon is the agreed upon
interest, so you should owe the
guy 7 dollars,
or 107 dollars the next period,
right?
Not 100 any more.
There's 7 percent interest.
Now you owe the guy 107, right?
But at that moment when you
owed him 107 you paid him 8.05.
So the guy says,
look, I lent you 100,
I expect 107 back next period,
you pay me 8.05.
That's 8.05,
so what's left that you owe me?
It's 100 minus the 1.05.
So 98.4 something,
so let me just say it again.
You borrowed 100.
The next year you owe 107.
We've already taken into
account the interest rate.
It's 107, so we're sitting in
next year.
We're no longer sitting back
here.
B_1 is as of next
year.
So you should really by rights
be owed now, the lender should
be owed 107 now because he lent
100 last year.
The agreed upon interest is 7
percent so he should be getting
107 this year.
What is he getting?
He's getting 8.05,
so what's left is 107 - 8.05
and that's what we have,
what's left is 107,
is exactly that.
Right, so this is 7 he got
paid, so if I write it this way
107 he got paid 8.05,
so 107 I'm just rewriting the
same thing,
107 - 8.05 is going to be the
new B_1,
which just happens to equal 90
whatever that is,
98.05, something like that,
98.95, right?
So this is 1.05,
so 1.05 plus this is 100.
So 107 - 8.05 is 98.95.
You agree with that, right?
Student: Yeah.
Prof: So what I'm saying
is a year later you were owed
107.
You were paid 8.05,
so obviously what's left that
you're owed is the difference,
98.95 and that's exactly what
the equation was that I wrote
before.
Any other questions?
So you can always divide a
mortgage payment into the
interest part--
so any mortgage payment X can
be divided into the interest so
now let's erase this and I'm
saying it in other words.
So your payments are X
everywhere to the last period
and your remaining balance is
going to be B_1,
B_2,
B_3 and
B_30 which is
obviously equal to 0.
So you can always get out of
the mortgage by paying--after
you make a coupon payment X you
can get out of it by paying
B_2.
So your mortgage payment is
going to be divided into the
interest, and then the scheduled
principal reduction.
So here you pay 8.05.
The interest was only 7 percent
so you've overpaid.
So that's why the balance goes
down.
That's the scheduled
balance--It's called principal,
but scheduled balance
reduction.
And if you want you can prepay
and pay off part of the
remaining balance,
any part you want to.
So let me say it again.
In some period,
let's say 3,
what could you do in period 3?
Well, by the time you've waited
to period 3 you've got to pay
the coupon X.
Now, the coupon X is way in
excess of 7 percent times
B_2.
It's 8 and 7 percent of 100 is
less than X.
We're already down to a balance
of B_2.
So the X is bigger than 7
percent of B_2.
So 7 percent of B_2
is the interest,
but on top of that you paid
more than that,
so that extra you paid reduced
the remaining balance.
That's the scheduled reduction
in the remaining balance.
You paid that off.
You had no choice about that,
but now in addition,
if you want,
you can pay the B_3
and get rid of the whole
mortgage.
That's the rules of a mortgage.
Is that clear to everybody?
So any mortgage that you get,
works by those rules.
So we have to figure out the
value of the mortgage.
Somehow I feel I'm going too
fast.
Could someone ask a question if
you're lost?
I need to pick out--yes?
Student: So what you
just said applies that as time
goes on you pay a bigger and
bigger chunk of the principal
with each successive payment?
Prof: Yes.
So the mortgage is called an
amortizing mortgage.
This was a great invention at
the time of the Depression,
after the Depression.
It probably had been invented
before, but was used in a big
way after that.
I don't know the person's name
who invented it.
First it has the property that
you're always paying more.
Because you're paying level
payments you must always be
paying your principal down.
That makes the lender safer and
safer because it's the same
house protecting his loan as
collateral.
We haven't come to collateral
and how the whole world depends
on collateral yet,
but believe me we're going to
get there.
And so we haven't gotten to
collateral yet,
but when we get to it,
the lender's protected by the
house.
The amount that's owed to him
started at 100.
It's getting lower every period
so he's feeling safer and safer.
That contrasts to the old
lenders during the Depression
who were at the most vulnerable
right at the end--
oh, I've lost it--most
vulnerable right at the end.
Here these lenders are getting
less and less vulnerable as time
goes on.
So that's the advantage of an
amortizing mortgage.
Now, it so happens that the
rate of amortization gets faster
and faster.
So these numbers start at 100
and stay pretty close to 100,
and then they go down pretty
fast, which is what his point
is,
and that's absolutely right.
And so if you look at the
remaining balances here in this
chart it started at 100,
went to 98, went to 97,96,
95, now 93,92,
90.
They're going down faster and
faster.
If you keep going you're going
to see that they start leaping
down from 76 to 73,73 to 70.
Now they're starting to go from
43 to 38.
They're really,
by percentages,
going way down really fast,
21 to 14 to 7 to 0.
So they go down really fast at
the end, the remaining balance.
But that's just the way the
amortizing fixed interest
mortgage works.
And now we want to think about
how to value it,
all right?
So the payment is 8,
the coupon that they agreed on
in the mortgage was 7 percent,
but that's different from what
the interest rate is in the
whole economy which is 6
percent, say.
So suppose the interest rate is
6 percent.
Why would it be that with a 6
percent interest rate today,
one year interest rate today,
why would it be that if the
interest rate was 6 percent
today--
too complicated,
this tree--if the interest rate
were 6 percent today why would
it be that the mortgage rate
that people would agree to--
so it could be 6 percent--why
is it that the mortgage rate
people could agree to--
so this is 7.3 percent and this
went down to 4.9 percent.
That's in that tree.
So you tell me,
why is it that when the
interest rate is 6 percent
today--
so everybody knows on average
it's going to stay around 6
percent,
and here I want to get a loan
from a bank to buy a house and I
put up my spectacular house as
collateral so the bank should
feel safe.
It's amortizing and all that.
They should feel safe as long
as they haven't lent me too much
money, right?
By the way, if my house is only
worth 80 dollars and they lend
me 100 then the bank is in
trouble.
If the house is worth 100 and
they lend me 100 the bank might
be in some vulnerable situation
if the house loses value.
So banks would have to be
stupid, as they were,
to make loans of the home value
almost equal to the house value,
but we're going to come back to
that.
So suppose the house is worth
way more than the 100 they lend
me.
The amount I'm owing the bank
is only going down,
so the house is protecting the
bank completely,
has no worries of me defaulting
because it'll just take my
house.
Let's take that case.
The interest rate in the
economy is 6 percent and here
the bank is charging me 7
percent mortgage rate.
That's what we agree on,
and of course when it charges
me 7 percent mortgage rate I'm
going to be paying 8 dollars
every month.
How could that possibly be fair?
Or to put it another way,
why does the bank have to
charge a mortgage rate that's
way above the starting interest
rate?
Why would it have to do that?
Why does it do it and why is
everyone willing to pay it?
You see what the question is?
Back there, yes?
Student: You have the
option of prepaying it.
Prof: Right.
I've got this really valuable
option, which of course the bank
realizes.
I can always get out of it.
I can pay the remaining balance
and get out of it.
Now, what am I hoping for when
I take my 7 percent mortgage out
from the bank?
What am I hoping for?
How am I going to make money,
the homeowner?
Yes?
Student: If the interest
rate rises.
Prof: Right,
so if there's some tremendous
inflation like there might well
be now,
some tremendous inflation in
the next 5 years--
this is a 30-year loan.
If in the next 5 years the
economy's in so much trouble and
we've got all these homeowners
under water and we owe so much
money to the Chinese we could
well see the Fed engineering a
gigantic inflation,
so the interest rate might go
up to 10 percent.
I'm continuing to borrow
effectively at 7 percent from
the bank.
How can you see that?
Because this remaining balance,
remember,
the whole way it's structured
is, the payments,
after a year,
the 100 I borrowed goes down to
B_1,
but it's like a 20 [correction:
29]
year mortgage where I've
borrowed B_1,
again, at 7 percent interest.
After the third year,
right, just after making my
payment the 27 years left of the
mortgage are treated explicitly
by the law of the contract as if
I borrowed B_3 dollars
at 7 percent interest.
So in other words,
a mortgage is like a contract
where every year I get to
re-borrow at 7 percent,
but I'm borrowing a smaller and
smaller amount.
So I perpetually get to borrow
at 7 percent,
but I have the option of
canceling the whole thing by
paying off the remaining
balance.
So I'm hoping that the interest
rate's going to go to 12 percent
and I'm going to be borrowing
still at 7 percent,
borrowing at 7 percent and
reinvesting it at 12 percent.
I'll make a killing.
I'm praying for interest rates
to go up.
Now, most homeowners think that
they're praying for interest
rates to go down,
but they just have it all
backwards.
They think if interest rates go
down they'll get a lower
mortgage with a lower interest.
They don't realize that the
present value of their future
payments, are going to go up.
So they should be hoping for
the interest rates to go up.
They should be hoping for a big
inflation and that's when
they're going to make money.
And the option that the
homeowner gains if interest
rates go up and the homeowner
can always get out of the
mortgage and pay it off if the
interest rates go down by paying
off the remaining balance,
that's tremendously valuable.
So how do we compute that value?
We have to do it by backward
induction.
You can intuitively see there's
some value, but you don't know
exactly what it is until you do
it by backward induction.
So here the payments are always
8.
The payments we said were 8.05
and 8.05 and then at the end
8.05.
So we know that at the end the
present value of what the bank
is going to owe,
the present value of how much
the homeowner is going to have
to pay,
let's do it that way,
it going to be 0.
So we know that at this point
the value that's left is 0
because there are no payments
after this final--that's year
30.
There are no payments after
that.
So assume that we've figured
out the value and we're working
backwards.
So we are at some node like
this one where we know the
interest rate and we want to
figure out what the value is
here just after the coupon
payment is made.
So what's the value?
Well, the homeowner has the
option of making--remaining
balance, remember,
was B_1,
B_2 and this is
B_30.
So at this node here this is 0,
this is times 0.
So we have B_0 = 100.
At time 1 the homeowner,
he's made the payment here,
so at time 1 he could just pay
B_1 and be out of the
whole thing,
or he could make his payment.
So if he makes his payment then
he owes the 8.05--
sorry, he's just made his
payment, so he could either get
out of the whole thing by paying
B_1,
or he could wait to see what
happens next period.
So half the time he's going to
go up,
so he's going to have to pay
8.05 and then he's going to have
a decision then to make,
but we're working by backward
induction.
We've already solved out for
what the value of his decision
is there.
So it's V_Sup half
the time he's going to have to
pay 8.05.
He's going to be down here,
and then he's going to have the
remaining--
he's going to have to decide
whether to pay off the remaining
balance or not,
and V_Sdown is that
decision,
because we've already figured
out whether he should prepay or
not here.
So that's it.
It couldn't be simpler.
At every node after the coupon
payment is made the guy has the
choice of paying or,
I mean, of prepaying,
paying off the remaining
balance or waiting until the
next period,
and then he has to pay the
coupon if he waits until next
period,
and if he doesn't pay the
coupon then...
Student: What happened
to the interest rate?
Prof: Oh,
what happened to the interest
rate?
Well, I forgot it.
So thank you.
So I have to put this in
brackets and multiply by 1 over
1.049.
That's what happened to the
interest rate.
I just forgot it.
So either he pays the remaining
balance or he waits,
and of course he has to
discount it by the interest rate
there which is 1 over 1.049
times 1 half times what happens
over here 1 half times what
happens over here.
And that's it,
and that's what I've written
down in the nodes.
So here are the interest rate
nodes and here are the present
value--so here's the
non-callable mortgage.
So the non-callable mortgage,
if the homeowner was so stupid
that he never prepaid and the
mortgage interest rate is 7
percent and the interest rate
starts at 6 percent that's
obviously great for the bank.
The guy's stupidly always going
to pay, never prepays,
the bank makes 109 dollars,
but if the guy is much smarter
than that he's going to call.
And now, lo and behold,
the value's only 95.55.
The option is so valuable that
even though the interest rate is
6 percent,
the mortgage rate is 7 percent,
the banker's incredibly
overcharging him,
and the guy will never default,
still the bank is getting a
terrible deal because the
option's so valuable to the guy.
So what is a bank going to do
in that case?
What would a bank do?
I mean, if you were the banker
what would you do?
The interest rate is 6 percent.
You can't control the interest
rates.
That's the whole economy.
Everybody's patience,
and impatience and all the
Fisher stuff,
is determining all these
interest rates.
What would you do?
You wouldn't charge 7 percent
as your mortgage rate.
You'd have to charge a higher
mortgage rate.
Maybe you'd charge 8 percent,
and so we could just change the
whole thing to 8 percent and
redo it, and you'll see that the
guy will do better.
So the mortgage rate,
let's put it as .075 instead of
.07.
So now the annual payment's
gone up and everything is going
to change.
And so the interest rate
process is the same.
If the guy never prepays it's
now worth 114,
and if the guy does prepay
optimally, well,
you still haven't gotten it
high enough.
You have to make it 8 percent,
maybe.
So the interest rate looks like
it'll have to get to a lot above
6 percent.
Maybe it'll have to go to 8
percent.
Maybe 8 percent isn't enough.
Well, on average--let's just
try .08 and now we can see how
that worked out.
Interest rate process is the
same.
Look at this.
If the guy never prepays it's
worth 120.
If he does prepay it's still
not enough.
So it's going to have to be 9
percent or something.
Now, typically if the interest
rate is 6 percent the mortgage
rate will be something like 7
and 1 half percent,
not the 9 percent or 10 percent
I'd have to get up to.
So why do you think that is?
Yes?
Student: Maybe there are
enough dumb people who don't
prepay to make up for the smart
people who do?
Prof: Exactly.
You have to count on the dumb
people.
That's an important fact of
life.
You not only have to count on
them, you have to count them.
So you have to figure out what
fraction of the population is
this that's only going to pay
you 98 in the end,
and what fraction of the
population is this,
they're going to pay you 120 in
the end.
And if you knew which of the
guys were the 120 guys,
what fraction were the 120 guys
and what fraction were the 98
guys you'd know what the thing
was worth.
So how far am I going?
All right, so if you're a
mortgage hedge fund,
my company is a mortgage hedge
fund.
That's what we started out with.
We quickly did these
calculations and now--
all right, so if you look at
the data you're going to find--
oh, by the way,
Sunday I'm having,
remember,
this extra class Sunday night
to tell you a little bit about
the real world,
so I'm going to save the
stories of all the data and
stuff until then,
but basically we look at how
people have behaved in the past.
So were doing this tree and
we're figuring out,
from this tree you can figure
out when the people should have
prepaid or not.
Actually the next tree,
if you have 1 dollar's worth of
principal,
if you assume that the original
principal was 1 dollar instead
of 100 and you always figure out
at every node what would 1
dollar's worth of principal be
there,
you can find out in an easy way
when people should prepay.
So here you can see where all
the 1s are is when they should
have prepaid.
I don't have time now to
explain that,
but anyway just a slight
modification of the tree shows
you when they should prepay.
So you can look at when people
should prepay and you can look
in the data at how many of the
people do prepay.
So you can go house by house.
It's public information.
Are these people prepaying or
aren't they prepaying?
How smart are they?
And you can deduce from having
watched them in the past miss
opportunity after opportunity to
prepay you know that these
guys--
now, it's not a matter of being
stupid,
in fact the smartest people
might be the ones not prepaying,
they're not paying attention or
maybe it's a real hassle for
them to prepay.
So we're going to come to the
reasons why they won't prepay.
So you have to calibrate how
many people are behaving
optimally and how many people
aren't,
and then you can judge how high
you have to set the interest
rate to make a reasonable
profit.
And I'm going to talk more
about that next time.